-Welcome back.
We're hanging out
with Aubrey Plaza now.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Aubrey!
-What?
-We love getting to know
our guests
here at "The Tonight Show,"
and I thought it would be fun
to do it while playing a game.
It's time to play "Guest Test."
Here we go.
-♪ Tonight Show Guest Test,
yeah ♪
-Alright, here's how it works.
Before the show, you answered
a series of "this or that"
type of questions.
And now our audience is gonna
try to guess your answers, okay?
Everyone has clickers
at their seats.
You can vote for either
answers "A" or "B."
We're going to do
five questions.
And here's the deal.
If our audience
gets at least three questions
right,
everyone here gets a free pint
of Tonight Dough,
Ben & Jerry's ice cream.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Wow. Wow.
-Alright, you guys,
how well do we know Aubrey?
Here we go. Aubrey, ready?
-Okay.
-Alright.
-What do I do?
-I'm just going to ask you.
Don't answer yet,
but we're all going kind of talk
and think about this.
First question is,
"Pizza or tacos?"
Now, I know
that you're from New York.
-Sure. No.
-No?
-I'm from Delaware.
>> Delaware.
[ Laughter ]
-Delaware?
Pizza or tacos, Delaware?
-Scrapple or cheesesteaks.
[ Laughter ]
-Exactly.
But you lived in New York.
-I did. I lived in New York.
-Now you live in L.A.
-And now I live in L.A., yeah.
Kind of. I don't know.
-New York has a lot of pizza.
-Yep.
-L.A. has a lot of tacos.
-Yeah. Yeah.
-Quest?
-It's hard.
-I think she's going to
choose tacos.
-Yeah, but then her accent
in "Emily the Criminal"
is very New Jersey.
You're kind of like going,
"Yeah, I didn't want this job."
[ Laughter ]
I think maybe your research --
-"You looking at me?
You think
you're better than me?"
-"You think you're
better than me?"
And then you add that pizza.
Maybe eat pizza in that.
So I'm going to say, pizza.
Higgs?
-Pizza.
-Yeah.
We're gonna say pizza, okay.
Everyone grab your clickers.
Press "A" for pizza,
"B" for tacos.
Let's look at the results
right here.
[ Drum roll ]
-Oh.
-Barely, pizza!
-Whoo!
-Aubrey, what was your answer,
pizza or tacos?
You said...
[ Drum roll ]
Yeah!
[ Bell ringing ]
-Come on!
-Yeah!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Boom! In your face. Yeah!
-I like pizza. so what?
-So what? So what?
Get over it.
-Get over it. It's pizza.
-So close to getting
a free pint of ice cream,
thanks to Aubrey Plaza.
But who knows what will happen?
-Ooh.
-The second question.
You were a former page --
an NBC page here.
-That's right.
-So my question is,
"Would you prefer the 1990s
NBC page uniform
or the current NBC page
uniform?"
There are the two choices there.
One had a little more flair.
-Mm-hmm.
-I kind of like that bow.
I want to see
what's up with that.
Where else could you wear it?
-Everywhere.
-Yeah, you wear it everywhere,
and you show people what's up.
-Yeah.
-I'm gonna go with
'90s page uniform.
-Is that thing real?
-I think she likes
the current one.
-You think Aubrey likes
the current one?
I think she's
very pro fashion-forward,
Aubrey Plaza, and
she would go for that one
and make that '90s one work.
-With the bow.
-Yes.
She is not a quitter.
She doesn't take the easy road.
Yes! '90s page.
What, you're saying --
-Current. I'm saying current.
-Alright, everyone,
let's look at the votes.
The results are in.
Audience said, '90s.
I'm with the audience.
What did Aubrey say?
-Whoa!
[ Bell ringing ]
-'90s!
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Laughs ]
-God!
-Quest. Quest, what's up, man?
-I thought I knew you.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, because of the bow,
it's fun.
-Oh, yeah.
I mean, look at me.
-To dress up.
-I mean, come on.
-Exactly, you're
a fashion person.
This is fantastic.
we might be getting
a free pint of ice cream.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Alright, we have three more
questions to go,
and there could be curveballs
that take points away.
[ Laughter ]
This question is,
"Blonde or brunette?"
-Oh.
-"This is a great question,
Jimmy.
Thank you, Jimmy."
-It's topical, it's topical.
-"Why is that a great question?"
Well, because we know Aubrey
as being a famous brunette,
but yet she's a blonde
right now.
"Oh, I see the conundrum."
-Why am I a blonde?
-Uh, whoo.
-Why would I do
something like this?
-Well, you look good
both directions.
Currently you're blonde.
-Is it because I like it, or...
-Yeah, no one knows.
Everyone's talking.
-They're talking amongst
themselves.
-Yeah, they're talking
amongst themselves.
There's a little kerfuffle
out there.
-Okay.
-Can we see the results here?
Audience says...
-Brunette.
-I'm going to say this. Yes.
I'm going to say
the audience is correct,
only because we know you,
you became a famous brunette.
-Mm-hmm.
-And so that, it's in our head,
you are a brunette.
-Uh-huh, that's right.
Good job, Jimmy.
-But you answered with...
[ Drum roll ]
-What?
-Whoa!
[ Bell ringing ]
-Ice cream!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-[ Laugh evilly ]
-Alright, we have
two more questions left.
If we get this wrong,
we're deducting three points.
-Ugh!
-Those are the rules.
I don't write the rules.
-You don't make them up.
-No, they've been around NBC --
For 60 years,
they've been doing this game.
-Yeah.
-We're not going to
change the rules tonight.
-No, we can't now.
-No, no, no, no.
-They changed the page uniform.
-Here we go.
It's a very simple question.
"Ryan Reynolds or Ryan Gosling?"
-Oh!
[ Audience oohs ]
-"A" or "B"?
Ryan Reynolds or Ryan Gosling?
-Oh, that's tough.
-Both charming leading men.
Studs, people would say.
Good actors.
Quest, what are you thinking?
-Reynolds.
-Ryan Reynolds.
Higgbo?
-I'm going to say
the Delaware in you
likes a little bit of Gosling.
[ Light laughter ]
-That's interesting.
-Excuse me?
-The water gap.
You know what I'm saying?
-What is that?
-Ryan Reynolds also is
just very --
-What did you just say to me?
-Ryan Reynolds, Canadian.
-Love Ryan Reynolds.
-Everyone loves Canadians.
-Yep. Everybody.
-I like them both.
-But it's not who you like.
-It's not who I like.
-No. It's who Aubrey likes.
-Aubrey chose.
And she might have chose
a trick thing.
-Oh, I want to say it
really bad.
-Alright, I'm going to say --
-I wanna say it.
-I'm gonna say
it's Ryan Reynolds.
Alright, audience,
let's see the results.
[ Drum roll ]
Audience said Ryan Reynolds.
Aubrey Plaza says...
Ryan Gosling!
[ sad tuba ]
-No ice cream for anyone
because of Aubrey!
-I don't know, I like him,
I like him, I like him.
[ Laughter ]
-Wow.
what -- this is -- what a turn.
-It's a barn-burner
-What a turn.
It's all down to
the last question.
if we get this correct,
everyone in here gets a pint
of Tonight Dough ice cream
from Ben & Jerry's.
This is the greatest ice cream
in the world.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Oh!
-With 100% of my proceeds
going to SeriousFun,
which is a great charity.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Ugh! A lot of stress.
-You alright?
-Aubrey, I'm so happy
you're here.
-I'm so sorry.
-I'm getting to know you,
and -- No.
I mean, don't say you're sorry.
You could be
giving us all ice cream.
We don't know.
-It's all stacked up
right behind the curtain, too.
It's melting. We got to go.
-Well, we'll see!
[ Laughter ]
it might go
right back to the freezer
if we don't get this one right!
-How many points is this one?
-This one is worth 10 points.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh.
-Alright, question is,
"Hawaii or Italy?"
[ audience oohs ]
I know what you're thinking,
but when you work in a location,
is it fun?
-Sometimes no.
-Sometimes it's work.
And I feel like,
if you live in L.A.,
you scoot over to Hawaii
all the time.
-Yeah, just scoot over,
five hours, a little scoot.
Scoot and a hop.
-You take your little
hot air balloon
over to Hawaii.
You're like, "Aloha!"
-You hop over. Aloha!
-You're very close to Hawaii
in L.A.,
but you had a good memory
in Italy,
and Italy kind of sticks
in your brain forever.
And it's something
that will always be there.
And you had the greatest
experience there
with a great cast, Mike White,
"White Lotus."
[ Light laughter ]
Quest, what do you say?
What, what?
-Aw, man, I --
-Come on, Quest.
-Hawaii.
-Hawaii?
-I'm gonna go with Hawaii.
-I'm going Italy
because of what happened
just now.
This experience changed --
Look, she has blond hair,
for heaven's sake.
-I get it, but...
-This is all new.
I'm saying Italy all the way.
-I'm going Italy 100%.
-Yeah, 100% Italy.
Audience, let's see
what your results --
what the audience said.
They went Italy!
Now, Aubrey, did you say
Hawaii or Italy?
Aubrey says...
[ Drum roll ]
Yeah!
[ Bell ringing ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-Yes! Thank you
for the ice cream!
Oh, my God!
Ice cream for everybody!
Thanks to Aubrey Plaza!
She's hosting
"Saturday Night Live"
this weekend on NBC.
You can stream
"Emily the Criminal" on Netflix.
We'll be right back
with Jalyn Hall, everybody.
Stick around.